marc fortin président de la section
québécoise du conseil canadien du
commerce de détail bonsoir monsieur
fortin je me suis forte est ce que vous
en dites quoi
oui je vous entends bien bonsoir
monsieur fignon bon très bien c'est
juste qu'un petit délai on va tenter
d'ajuster sa aldo rythme est ce que
d'autres détaillants pourrait se placer
comme ça à l'abri de leurs créanciers
c'est quand même deux mois que plusieurs
de ses détaillants n'ont pas eu de
revenus ou très peu de revenus
vous avez tout à fait raison ça fait
presque trois mois même parce que le
dernier trois semaines avant le départ
il ya les revenus commencé à fondre
beaucoup donc c'est ça fait un certain
temps que les revenus sont minces les
loyers doivent toujours être payés parce
qu'il ya pas beaucoup de de l'attitude
qui a été donnée de ce côté là les taxes
d'affaires les taxes foncières donc on
regarde les revenus fixes
ce que n'ont pas les revenus et les
dépenses fixes ce sont des dépenses qui
sont très importantes
puis qui ont besoin des pays qui créent
des grands problèmes de liquidités pour
tous les détaillants cependant est ce
que les premiers à tomber sont les
détaillants qui n'allait déjà pas très
bien l'écouter c'est sûr qu'il y en
avait certains détaillants avait
peut-être des pressions financières un
peu plus présent donc on voit aux états
unis justin j crew qui ont
malheureusement tombé on voit maintenant
halde ou qu'ils se protègent la loi de
protection des faillites on voit que
rythm and fait la même chose mais vous
comprendre aussi que en ce moment avec
les propriétaires de centres d'achat
depuis huit semaines que tout le monde
essaie de négocier l'ouverture n'était
pas très présente donc sa cause des
problématiques
on a certains nos membres qu'ils ont des
millions de dollars en frais de loyer à
chaque mois un certain moment était
d'utiliser les liquidités disparaissent
dont des banques
c'est une que vous accueillez très bien
le début de la réouverture dans la
grande région de montréal lundi prochain
à un peu la dame nous l'a dit dans votre
reportage nous sommes très contents très
excité nous avons entre aimer ça vient
avec un lot de responsabilités aussi il
va falloir mettre en place différents
contrôles différentes gestion sanitaire
pour s'assurer que les clients soient en
sécurité et les employés sont en
sécurité ou si vos entreprises sont
prêtes
oui ils sont prêts parce qu'on le vit
depuis presque dix semaines déjà avec ce
qu'on appelle les essentiels donc les
pharmacies les épiceries les
quincailleries
donc on a eu un grand apprentissage des
protocoles ont été bâtis les protocoles
ont été échangés avec les marchands dans
d'autres industries d'autres catégories
afin de les aider à les adapter puisse
préparer donc tout le monde est en train
de vraiment d'avancé de l'avant les gens
veulent reprendre leur entreprise parce
que si on reste fermée encore 6 8
semaines on va parler de fermeture par
tous et de rue complètement ville donc
il faut repartir parce qu'on y est on
est pas très d'étirer l'élastique en ce
moment donc en repartant la machine je
pense que tout le monde doit être en
meilleure position où il ya des frais
supplémentaires pour assurer la sécurité
de tout le monde mais les gens sont
prêts à le faire puis l'ont démonté ce
soit paul code dans les centres
commerciaux qui avaient été évoquées
aujourd'hui la possibilité d'ouvrir par
exemple la porte arrière d'un commerce
êtes vous d'accord avec ça parce que le
gouvernement dit non alors que ce soit
la porte avant la porte utilisées par
les gens ouais mais il ya certains
commerces qui ont commencé à l'extérieur
de montréal à ouvrir avec la porte
arrière
ça s'est très bien déroulé il y avait
une ouverture de la part du gouvernement
que l'on puisse justement le faire de
cette façon là mais les yeux un petit
recul donc ça risque de crise certains
problèmes pour certains détaillants qui
avait déjà commencé à l'excellent de
montréal à fonctionner de cette façon là
qu'ils avaient mis des protocoles des
systèmes pour pouvoir fonctionner comme
ça mais maintenant le gouvernement nous
dit une porte vraiment une porte
d'entrée qui donnent sur l'extérieur
donc le flou rencontre en conséquence
mais ça risque de crise certains
problématique mais vous savez dans
beaucoup d'autres un peu partout dans le
monde
les centres d'achats sont réouverts il
ya des bons contrôles en place il ya des
gens qui font la sanitation il ya des
équipes qui ont été engagés pour le
contrôle pour nettoyer pour bien gérer
le trafic dans les centres d'achats donc
il ya moyen de le faire sentir soi
problématique
nous ne sommes pas encore là à montréal
un gros québec
alors j'espère qu'on volait qu'assez
rapidement pour donner un peu d'oxygène
et ces entreprises là parce que sinon ce
que service de cause et dans quelques
mois c'est vraiment des fermetures
complètes on va se retrouver des rues
vides et des centres d'achats mois qui
viennent c'est parce qu'on veut non plus
skf le dit vous vous attendez dans le
temps après la crise un peu plus tard
est ce qu'il y ait moins de commerce
physique et beaucoup plus de vente en
ligne
définitivement ce qu'on voit dans le
commerce en général on est passé de 3 %
dans l'alimentation à peu près à 16 17 %
des ventes en ligne on est passé d'à peu
près 5 à 7 % dans le commerce général
vêtements à 20 24 % des achats en ligne
donc pu y voir une croissance mais c'est
pas assez pour pouvoir créer des
liquidités pour les entreprises et
supporter toutes les infrastructures
qu'elles ont en place donc oui ça va
augmenter
quand on regarde le dos quand on regarde
reitman une des possibilités ou une des
dvd des raisons pour laquelle elles sont
en protection c'est qu'elle doive
renégocier avec leurs fournisseurs
toutes les lignes qui ont été payées ou
qui doivent être payées elles doivent
renégocier avec les bayards dont les
propriétaires de baux dans les centres
d'achats ça va être la seule façon de
faire bien on s'arrête fille marc fortin
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup